okay hi everyone
joining the live stream we are starting
our
season
of design reviews for version 13.1
um
and
we are starting today with sound and
vision
um
so give me some sketch of what we're
going to be seeing here we've got image
video image
import export okay
all right
uh
all right so this is under the hood
stuff support
the new version of ffmpeg
yes
okay
gui updates for video
your own resource object so do we have
video capture yet yes we do
okay so then i can i can presumably say
here if i wanted to
i could say
uh
i could start saying video capture
and
splatteroo i saw that yesterday but i
think it's working
if you
open the opener you should see a
thumbnail of what is being captured
well there it is
and i i think even if you start
recording everything should work it's
just uh some prototype
box
okay that we're seeing here
cool
all right
so i recorded that so now what do i do
oh there we go
okay
well that's really cool okay so then
fine
uh
so now let's take that video what can i
do with that video
so if i take that video
and if i
when it just beeps when i try and copy
from it
so it looks like an image but it is
there's a frame there basically
there's that frame if you want to copy
the frame or copy the whole video now i
want to copy an image i want to copy
this this
frame from the video if you right-click
copy images the first one
cool
okay um
so i see so this video so for example i
could take this video
and i could say on line one i could just
say
uh video
video time series
video map time series
what's video time series
that one was uh obsoleted at the time of
12. okay so how do i get the average
color
um mean
by the way that that i don't know you
guys know this but that um
uh debugging technology using video that
i kind of push people do do you realize
how do you know how beautifully that
works have you seen the results from
that
or you know nothing about this
i don't
this is really very interesting this is
a wolfman alpha debugging thing
where we just look at the we capture the
website
and we look at the mean color
and then every transition on the website
shows up as a change in the mean color
and we then do peak fitting to find
those moments of change and then we use
that to compute the uh response times
and it works beautifully
okay
okay it's a great application really
that should have been that by the way
should have been mean of slot image
because video map time series takes
an association as you see their time
audio image
okay
okay
do we yet have this as timeless plot i
mean
okay so that's not very exciting because
i wasn't i mean that's that's um
we can't tell very much from that
um
although i i do have to try something
i'm just going to try one thing i'm
sorry just because i'm playing here and
i want to understand this i really like
video capture that's really nice that
that just works
that's great
and is it fairly robust i mean other
than whatever bug is it is right now
um i would say so this is blocking we
have we should look at the design of
video capture there is a non-blocking
version of that that we have also
implemented the design is not our usual
design but we do have it in file name
center
i have a stupid brace thing on my finger
because i'm
because of my stupid repetitive motion
injury from using my mouse in a stupid
way
ah
okay let's see whether we can
um
line five
i am curious whether i can see
me kind of waving at things
not sure how much it's affecting the
mean color though
let's look at it
yep there it is
isn't that cool
sure
i mean this was really useful for
debugging for this you know website
debugging type thing
um
so there's no other way to instrument it
no all the other instrumentation gave
the wrong answer all the instrumentation
that's done from server side the
javascript it all gives the wrong answer
but you know i could kept on saying this
thing is slow i can get out my stopwatch
and i can see it slow
so let's just capture the video and then
we see you know in that video just like
in this case here
you see you know much of it there's not
much change and then something happens
and you can detect something happening
and you can measure those times
and it's very precise i mean you know
it's um
okay let's let's look at the um
uh can we can we look at this um
uh
uh what am i trying to say can we by the
way this i would recommend this as an
example something like this i mean not
this particular one but but i think this
is a nice example of video capture
you know and even video capture from the
screen you know maybe visiting a website
would be a nice example sure okay
um
so let's see i skipped ahead to video
capture but let's take a look at this um
video those those subsections there you
should open too those are kind of nice
future you know failure cases which i'm
saying
has that been designed or is that just
um
yep that has been designed
is that really what we want for a file
that is slightly outdated but the icon
is the same can we can we please check
with design about that i this doesn't
strike me as i because we've got a lot
of standardization of file icons for the
cloud
we can contact bailey again
but yeah okay but ask him if it's
consistent with the icons for the cloud
okay
um
here i think there should be less space
between those two lines but that's um
make sure the file path the file path
make sure the file path is typed
correctly
okay
that's for a new file
i would think
well no no this doesn't make sense
file not found
that's not the right instruction right i
mean it's like
either the file path is typed in
correctly in which case you need to
retype it
or you can browse to find a new file
those are two different actions i don't
understand why they're connected like
that
they can both fix that kind of
appearance right
you can either have it i understand it
has a completely different file
could you please find out whether we've
got whether we've had similar messages
in the cloud yeah i'm pretty sure we
have
yep
um
that's the minimized version of this
right correct
how come there's any little critter
behind the picture here why is this not
just uh
why isn't it's just blank behind here
we're caching that one frame
we're saving that one frame
in the notebook
so this is a video that was at some
point valid at that point that frame was
extracted then the just remains okay so
so that is analogous to
the thing about wherever it was file not
stored in notebook right
this is the other case a file not stored
in notebook
and and you don't have it locally
because i i i understand i understand
exactly there's a there's another
version of that i don't think this is
right okay so there's another version of
that when you have a data set
and it is you know not stored locally
you come back again
and um
uh
the um
what am i trying to say you come back
again
um
um
and the data isn't there we give some
other indication
okay we give another error condition for
the data set do you know what i'm saying
yes the question is is that a
recoverable uh issue like no it's not
probably
because this is recoverable
well it may be recoverable if you have a
file path yeah
okay so so can we
okay maybe we need billy here or i don't
know but we need we need somebody who
knows about the data set failure case
okay because that needs to be aligned
with this i don't object the
functionality is great i'm just saying
let's get the iconography consistent
i'll see if i can get billy in
okay
um
okay and the other failure case is
similar below there
that's just to minimize no below below
oh it's open
start this i don't understand this
download file to enable gui
in other words
resource not found
these are fairly confusing i want to
know what we've done in other cases and
then we'll loop back to this okay
okay okay because i think we've got
wording that's almost identical for
these other cases so let's try and make
it consistent that sounds good but the
idea here in all of these cases is the
degree is partially broken but you can
click your way around to fix it that is
i understand chronography can
yeah we can look at making the
iconography better yeah but i like the
concept the concept seems just fine yeah
okay
um okay is this is there new stuff here
this is something that you actually
asked for which makes sense which means
that the gui remembers where what play
position you were at
right
so playback settings is now a um
uh do i should i look here at playback
settings
yes that's a that's an actual option for
video
does it have a name that's consistent
with other names and things
um playback settings
the what is the units of playback
position
seconds
you need to say that here
yep
can you get frames by using units
we should if you're not context but that
seems like an easy thing to add yeah
yeah
okay
so
when i bring back a video
and let me understand the relationship
of this to animations
if i have a notebook and i'm running an
animation
not with video but just an ordinary
animated animation
um
and
what am i trying to say and um
uh
um and i close the notebook i reopen do
does the animation come back in the same
place or does it reset
can we make sure we know the answer to
that and try and get some consistency
there i believe if it's paused you'll
get it back at that post pause location
that's what we do a lot in our
documentation examples but if it's not
paused it's probably starting from the
beginning but but you're doing the same
thing here with video pausing right yes
okay fine
video transparency what's that about
an option that says whether they created
video file should should have
transparent frames or not
i see by transparent you mean if there's
a picture of a dancing turtle in the
middle
but it's otherwise transparent
the dancing turtle could be superimposed
in another dancing elephant or something
exactly
okay but normally is there an alpha
channel normally in videos no it's very
rare and that's why with our processing
we thought it would be really handy to
have transparent videos generated as a
middle stage
but for the final production it's very
rare to have transparent videos
what does i understand what does video
transparency do
so for instance remember the example we
had with the rotating logo uh wolfram
logo on the side when we want to call
image rotate on that logo while creating
it it would be nice
it would be necessary to say that we
would like to keep that generated
rotating logo video as a transparent
video so that we can superimpose it on
another video but how do you make a
video i don't understand if i take a
video like like um the fish for example
here i mean that video has
values of pixels everywhere how do i
quotes make it transparent
say if it had a constant background
around it remove background could have
been used video frame map remove
background could have been used to
remove the consistent
background okay
let me do an example here let me just
see if i can do an example okay so i've
got a fish video here and now how do i
get the color
let me do this for sort of in a um
in a coherent way okay let me just see
whether i can make this workflow work
okay so first of all i want to grab
that fish
so i'm going to say copy image i'm going
to get that i want to measure
the value in there how do i how do i
measure a value is it this one here
yes
okay so go there
quite why it says lowercase r lowercase
g lowercase b i have no idea
if you click there there should be a
copy
uh color color value or something there
is a copy button
well uh bottom left bottom right yeah
copy
color values
okay
oh for goodness sake what the hell
i know this should be scale
this is divided by 255 that's going to
be our rgb horrifying
for goodness sake let's get this right
okay nope i'm so skeptical about what
happens when i when i was displaying
those things it had that lowercase rgb i
mean it would be nice to get that right
okay so anyway i can get an rgb color
of this thing
okay there we go there's a teal fish
okay now what i want to do is i want to
get colors near that color i want to
make those i i just want to learn how to
do this i want to make transparify the
head of the fish how do i do that
color color detect that image come on
outline
we had color replaced right
yeah why not red shoe
uh oh image recolor
yeah that's the one
the red shoe
yeah
i'm going to recolor this and then i
want color
colors near that thing comma how much
0.1
arrow
transparent
okay so it went quite transparent there
okay so now i want to do that
for this video here
just trying to understand how to do all
these things so i want to say
video i want to go video to video so i
want to say video frame map is that
correct
yep
of this thing
uh
that thing and i want to make that a
hash image
i think in this case it's just hatch
because this video
yeah go ahead
okay it's quite zippy actually okay
there we go all right so now we've got a
transparent fish
so i don't think this is a transparent
fish because we didn't specify the video
transparency option this is where the
trans the transparent color has been
replaced by white so this is where you
want to
specify video transparency goes to true
i think
and what in the video framework
yes
the function generates the video okay
video transparency
goes to true
is that okay
that should be okay
and it takes longer time because the
encoding is different
okay
[Music]
okay fine all right now i want to
superimpose that on a video of something
else
how do i how do i superimpose that on
top of a video of um
of i don't know what let's let's flip
this video around let's say image image
reflect or something
okay just for fun
so if i say video frame map
of that image and i want to say image
reflect here
that should be all that you need
don't forget the transparency because i
don't care about transparency in this
case it shouldn't make any difference
given that there is no
image reflected now i want to
superimpose this image on this one how
do i do that you should be able to do um
video overlay
and then
let me see overlay video
yeah yes
okay
and then i say percent 12 common percent
13.
i think percent first one is the
background i think i think so
so the other era yep
i see background comma whatever okay
13 comma 12.
[Music]
it's kind of difficult to see i guess
it's kind of difficult to see isn't it
but but you do see the orange fin right
yes you do
all right
very cool and quite zippy too well done
okay let's go on with the review i'm
this is this is good video transparency
is that the right name for this
at some point we call this encode
transparency to say whether in the in
the final resulting file we would like
the transparency to be encoded or not
yeah that's confusing
yeah um
that's what roger what about
use video transparency or something or
use
include
i really what it is it's include
transparency or not
and why is it the case that in this case
here they don't get some kind of message
saying your transparency will be ignored
um you're unsure if that's necessary
um
well i mean if i give explicit
transparency you just throw it away
shouldn't you tell me
um
actually i'm not sure does that happen
if you especially if you don't specify
the video transparency option
yes that's what we just we just yeah
sorry yeah
we just
right in this case here
well in that case there we've got we've
got it but in this case here
we don't have it
it's just ignoring the transparent there
so i think it should generate a message
in that case
okay
and then
yeah i mean video transparency
i guess it's okay
yeah i guess that's okay
all right video encoding
enable specifications of but we had
video encoding before
yes
we're just allowing for some presets
like
uh what's the encoding speed and uh for
what are we fine-tuning like is it still
image film and so forth so sometimes the
encoding speed is goes faster with those
settings and sometimes we get a smaller
file if we can optimize for those
presets like it's all that still image
or
decode fast
so these are named presets
correct
some available tunes are
did you mean
tuning so there are there are two two
keys to the association of video
encoding and encoding speed and tune
i agree
is that what they're called in the
industry
yeah yeah you tune it for something
well i mean usually we have a
performance goal
that's our usual name for a thing like
this
kind of yes
but these are
i mean this is richer
this is a richer space right this is a
still image
yep and and it is very much encoder
dependent these are not available for
everything that's just some
where this has been developed that the
list is in front of you in the excluded
cell the last cell in the notes
yeah i understand okay
to me
i mean if you're going to use
some following sub options
so how do you give the sub options it's
the encoder name
in the list and then the you know
encoding speed arrow blah
i should have an example
okay
i think this should be called encoding
optimization or encoding
tuning otherwise you got to call this
one speed
see what i'm saying
sure
and encoding tune or encoding tuning
i mean maybe it's a goal really encoding
goal
this is this is what
yeah
um what we optimize for basically
and the user is indeed specifying a
video encoding option so maybe this
speed is better than encoding speed so
maybe the encoding part can be dropped
together in the sub options
well then then
um carlo aren't we using video encoding
as an option for import as well to
specify i think we should leave the
decoder
i think we should
i think we should say
encoding speed arrow and then we should
say encoding goal arrow
and then here we should say
you know optimization optimized for
animations of cartoons and so on
optimized for
whatever
don't call it zero latency if it's
really low latency
i mean it's not going to achieve zero
latency unless i mean i suppose its goal
could be zero latency but it will never
achieve it
i think we try to stay as close as
possible to
what those tunes are called
if it's called zero maybe this is the
same as zero gravity is really
microgravity
well yeah
right or five g is you know whatever
right
yeah i'll look into it if it's not
explicitly called that i agree low
latency would be better but if it's
explicitly called zero latency no and
also fast decode fast decoding i mean
all of these if these are industry
standard names
look if these are unlisted names and
they're called tunings then we should
call this encoding tuning
okay
but if they're not industry standard
names i think we should call it encoding
goal and then name these appropriately
we were looking at ffmpeg for most part
i'll look elsewhere as well to see what
it's called in the in the industry
okay optional third argument third
element for presets
so basically accessing that or returning
those available presets in dollar video
encoders
wow
i mean i don't understand how you could
do that given that one of them is a
speed
thing
um
ah
wrote on our live stream says zero
latency is the industry's standard name
like zero gravity
right
the okay over here
so women so you've got in some of these
you've got oh there we go so
i don't understand this this is this is
a discovery interface but how the heck
do i use it
because what you're giving me here is i
mean this is a very weird discovery
interface where i might say so
because i can't actually pick this up
and use it
i've got the set of all possible
see what i'm saying
i thought what you're going to give me
was
libx 264
you know encoding tuning arrow still
image
libx 264 encoding
yeah whatever something like the other
product of those possible things
um
but then encoding speed is
really crazy it's crazy because it's a
real number
so that's not going to work
um
when have we ever had a thing like this
i mean we're
you know this is a discovery thing
i don't know
voice style data is the closest thing
that comes to mind
some something like that
voice styles
but we've also got voice style data
voice style data yes
you know i was playing with this
oh
you know i i i keep on telling you i
think a much better way to do this
rather than having all these weird
little functions it's just document an
entry in the function repository
and let people pull things out of that
when they need to
i'm not buying yeah go ahead i i'm not
buying this i'm sorry i think this is so
unusable because somebody could map over
a bunch of encoders or
you know i don't know what people are
going to want to do i mean they might
want to map over encoders and see what
the smallest file is or something like
this
how are people going to use this
whatever they're going to do this is not
computer usable
i was thinking is there anything we
could do in the style of wolfram
language data because this is kind of a
similar discovery
it is yes it is
it's a good question
honestly i think this is not worth
putting in i think it's more confusing
than i think i mean this stuff here
is
that's its human name is that correct
yeah it's kind of a description that we
gathered from a fember yes
god this is a mess
i mean i don't know how you use this
stuff i mean okay for something i mean
in a way this is a little bit like
dollar import formats or dollar export
formats or something
but yeah
that is exactly the same thing except
that this has more metadata
yes
i mean i mean that third richer is sort
of a little bit richer description okay
you just broke anybody who had code that
used this
right by now adding that third element
there you just broke their code
i don't think so so we thought about
that if we broke that code
the the reason why i say i don't think
so is that the part that people were
using previously was just the first
element of all this list for each codec
which does which gives you
the computable element that you can use
as value how are people using this
that is a good question i i don't have a
truthful answer here how i use it is i i
usually grab the format that i'm
interested in
and just look at the
all comma one part of the result so i
just get that first bit now that we have
the encoding speeds i might look at that
third one as well what do you use it for
in general i mean it's like i've got a
video
i'm going to put it out there i'm going
to use you know v408 format or something
yeah so i come within with ideas on what
i already want to know and i want to
know how dart is called in the vulcan
language so i can express it as an
option
okay but but hold on
why do you want to know this because
you've got some particular kind of
device that wants v408 format or yeah or
i'm uploading to a specific service that
requires a specific codec or i know
okay but but have we curated okay so
you're you're uploading to youtube let's
say yes what codec does it require so so
for stuff like that we do have shortcuts
for example video transcode has a
youtube target that does things smartly
okay but but i want to know
realistically how people are going to
use this list
so one answer one thing is you're
uploading to a service
and
seems to me i mean i don't know whether
we have a service connect that directly
does that if we don't we should have i
think what we want to do is to publish
command is what the
end user
that could be a service connect as well
but that's the kind of that's not for
users that's for developers type thing
right
yeah no i agree but but but it's going
to need authentication and things like
that which absolutely
that's what part of what publish needs
to do
right
but i i agree with you this is not a
great
uh
as a discovery interface
i mean i would prefer to see a
you know a data set in the
you know in the data repository with
more human readable things and maybe you
know it could have all kinds of stuff in
it
but then you realize at this point this
is also platform specific these are the
the encoders
it needs to be computed at the on the
user's machine unfortunately i see
edmund livestream is pointing out surely
this needs a data set named entities
that's a good point too
i mean this is very primitive in many
ways
i mean in in
like these formats could be entities for
example in which case they can have
properties
yes for sure um the one thing i will
point out is that hopefully most of the
users how do you discover entities
there's no discovery interface for
entities yes there is what would you
like to what about
what is it
well what aspect of it do you want to
know do you want to know the list of all
entities of a given type
yeah
okay i mean like how do you discover the
list of possible entities
okay
um
entity list of element for example
that they are i mean if i do that for
cities it'll be pretty long
right and so each one of these
i can say
uh
enter the properties of that thing
and there are the properties
right
so if we had that
i mean i'm not necessarily saying we
want to go that heavyweight but if we
had that for video
uh encoders
that would be a mechanism that you know
already exists
so the the last thing i want to point
out is that
most users hopefully will not care about
this because we provide decent default
choices i understand
yeah i understand
i
understand
i don't think it's it's worth the effort
if you think the
addition of the third argument is
making this not useful or usable
um i would be happy to remove that from
that third part and just document them
that's what i think we should do for now
i think we're going to have a different
solution that either involves entities
or data set
that is the right way to do the full
discovery interface
okay by the way
says look inside any of rme rme's
manuals
whether they are for information about
these names rme
um
current and former rme products okay
don't know what these are okay
huh okay
um
we're just saying but for entity lists
of the codex how do you store
permutations like versions
i see yeah again
of codex
how do you put the qualification well
we've got density instance
you know like we can say one gram of
neodymium we could say version such and
such this is complicated and i i think
you know there's a good question here
which is
for
i mean right now
for like our import export formats
versioning is not a huge issue those
things don't rev that quickly
do they rev quickly in the case of video
codecs well for example so they are
first of all they are very platform
dependent and what kind of installation
of effect that you have or we provide
but for example there are several codecs
that are introducing this switch to
version five
is mentioned at the beginning of good
notes
but but the old codecs they don't change
new ones may get added support for old
ones may get dropped but with a single
specific one it it stays steady
so what is the what is the negotiation i
mean does the codec that i can use on my
machine depend on my video card and
things
it does
you for example if you had a windows
machine with an nvidia card you might
get some nvidia hardware accelerated
codecs on mac you have you might have
some video toolbox accelerated codecs
and it all depends on also if you're
using this dilation of a ffmpeg that we
provide within our layout which is more
limited for licensing issues
or if you installed your own on your
machine okay but how is the negotiation
done so i've got a
you know i've got some random video and
it's in with some particular codec
and
well then i'm going to upload it to
well no let's take youtube for example
it probably stores videos in multiple
codecs is that true
i think so
well
i know it does i know it does the
and then how does it do the negotiation
with the machine to know which version
to download
i assume that is done to uh
informational exchange with the browser
but i don't know the specifics
but isn't that an issue for us like you
point at a video file
well
that we just relied to ffmpeg's default
choices
it it detects which codec it is uh
encoded in and then it has some default
choices of what so when i pointed an m4
file could that mp profile mp4 file
contain multiple versions of the video
with different codecs or is that not the
case um
if the video contains multiple tracks
yes
but it would just be
when you did that when you
play track one we'll use one codec
and when you play track two we will use
the appropriate codec as well but it's
not
it has different copies of the same file
just with different codecs
it usually is unique
okay
well i'm not sure if youtube i'm
are you really sure youtube is storing
different codecs i think it's once it
can probably take as input videos of
different codecs but i think at the end
it's storing it as
h.264 it for sure serves at a different
resolution so
yeah yes yes and that is what the
negotiation
usually happens i assume depending on
actually i yes i i i actually happen to
know more
uh yeah yes i i did once get an
explanation of how this works
and i mean it's basically watching how
fast the player is managing to you know
consume stuff and so on
and it is
yeah
all right let's keep going here to a
video
all right so
there is another version of this if you
click on that tour video new
okay
okay
i see so this is allowing it to zoom to
have a particular rectangle
by the way is it always the case that
every video display is rectangular
yes as far as i know
i haven't seen anything that is not
i mean you can certainly get displays
that are not rectangular i mean i
remember i don't know what's happened to
that company there was a company making
a um uh
a digital pocket watch which was a
circular display
nice i think
i i don't think it can be stored in any
of the with any of the core math
right no i think they were just storing
they were just chopping off the edges of
a rectangular
display
okay
all right fine
so then uh there are no examples of it
right no examples of it but i think
examples like find faces of people or uh
you know anything similar to that would
just be made a lot easier
go from one elephant to another because
those are all coming back as rectangles
i see i see icic
and we're going to interpolate correctly
yeah
um
okay
video record
that is in fact still carlo how are we
getting that this release
there are problems with
there is nothing new in the function
itself uh the function is exactly as it
was in the previous versions
we just have backend issues on uh um
linux and windows that we are hoping to
get uh wrapped up for 13 1.
okay hold on i didn't even know this
existed so this is this is the analog of
current
screen image right
kind this this returns
a handle to the recording process like
audio record
okay so i would like to say
if i do current screen image for example
okay
let's go over here
um
and i say current screen image
okay
um
so it's
captured a bunch of screens
but um probably
if you say
one or two whichever is your screen of
interest
okay there we go
um
so
it would be nice if we could do current
screen video
that's video capture
i know but how do you give it an i mean
it has an imaging device option
[Music]
slightly that we
yes we debated this we're not thrilled
about the name there is more about video
capture if you just want to open that
page see that not blocking as well
okay
video capture not video screen capture
however i don't mind splitting that into
video capture from webcams
and video screen capture yeah it seems a
sensible thing to do to me
i think video screen capture actually
that was
that was what we
originally had initially
um
okay
so
there there is a little bit of
awkwardness with that dynamical variable
that you should know of
as as a way of getting a non-blocking
capture
interface do you get an unblocking okay
audio capture how do you get an
unblocking interface
that
we don't but we were thinking if this
design gets approved then we could uh
make that change in audio capture as
well what does it do for the with the
dynamic variable though
it behave behaves essentially like file
name set of dynamic variable once the
recording is finished the value is
assigned the video is assigned to var
it behaves like a controller yeah i
understand
this idea of having a dynamic and a
non-dynamic version bothers me
i think you should talk to the front end
team about doing that yeah we've been
talking with lou mainly well i've been
talking with you mainly what does luke
have to say about this he doesn't have
any immediate objection he was worried
about some implementation details but he
was i actually just checked once with
john okay
yeah i mentioned to him but i never got
a review of the idea
okay
all right so
go ahead
um
okay i recommend given you know
look when i did that video capture just
now it just worked i mean i had multiple
webcams and things like that but it
managed to pick up the primary and it
just worked
so i'm a happy camper there
but on the other hand if i'm fussing
around with a screen and i'm resetting
the imaging device i don't even know
what the imaging device is for my screen
what is it
so by the way there is the menu
[Music]
button
that you could if you don't want to
specify an option textually you can poke
today look for example when i use zoom
and i have a
video input i don't believe one of those
video inputs can be my screen
that's not what i'm saying people yeah
no i agree that the name is not ideal um
right people are not used to that and i
am not against splitting this into
capture and screen capture
okay
now i mean i think it would also be
interesting and very relevant for our
course tools for example if you could
screen capture a particular rectangle on
the screen can you do that that is one
of the this is something that we have
trouble on linux and windows and we are
hoping to fix for this version
but yes both a rectangle or a notebook
object is something that
uh
see the second table there
um stephen yeah i see it the notebook
object is beautiful if we can do that
yep
however if you resize
if you resize the notebook you're still
stuck to the initial size of the
notebook but apart from that which
should be expected because frames needs
to have same size but apart from that
everything works fine
that live stream is interesting too
because that's also not something one
would necessarily expect
so that is something that we need to
make sure is a bit more robust i'm not
that is
needs to be tested a bit more okay i
thought we removed it from one of the
docs but yes
from video recording i think okay now
from capture
what's the difference in video recording
video capture video record has excellent
it's just a lower level uh video record
is basically programmatic
yeah okay fine and we have an audio
record similarly you know so you can
programmatically start exposing it and
all that right
okay so this
um
so current screen video would be
the analog of current screen image
do we want to call it that or video
screen capture
video screen capture seems better to me
okay
frame list
video was requested multiple times
this is yeah many people here on the
calls and the design you know you have
like a whole directory full of files
yes
and you want to just video
yeah you want to you know snarf them all
in basically
so you do a file uh
you do file names of that file
of that directory you hope that there's
an ordering criterion and then you make
a framelist video from
yes yeah yes
okay
sounds good to me
okay video support and image functions
remove alpha channel now supports video
okay cool
cool
video intervals
scene detection oh
so that is a bit of an
we've just had discussions the last few
days and we
the updates are in
a tentative function called the video
scene detect
but it is a recent development
of what
video intervals
right open video scene detect
instead
it's so recent stephen that it came in a
few hours ago yeah okay okay
just say
yeah i get it
scene
oh video scene
so you were 10 minutes late and we
showed it to roger just then
okay fine
so
just uh well maybe i should let you
comment first well but what is a scene
boundary how you mean that's a time
stamp okay so you're asking exactly what
i'm asking
what what's the definition of a scene
and i think that we should have
different objectives or goals of what
kinds of scene it is scenes we want to
detect
and they are now listed as
methods down there
but i think that that's basically like a
second argument that's like what well so
so this exactly would relate to this
testing application that we have
in other words yeah could we just use
that for you know when do the web page
load type thing
and i'm not completely certain that it
wants to be video scene detect as
opposed to video change detect
so event
so in your case you have events
yeah
i i really think at some point we need
to add a video position or some
something like that uh an addition to
video intervals something that says when
things happen
what you mean what's going to return
though
i mean one possibility like geoposition
we have something that represents a
point in a video just like we have a
point on the earth
i think what it means though is like
video intervals or terms a a list of
start and then for each
scene or thing
uh something that returns a single time
like there is an event at this time not
an event within these two times
is it was that what no i understand but
i'm making a different suggestion which
is a symbolic rapper called video
position
analogous to geo position
what what is that what is it
which you're thinking is gonna have a
time and a maybe a special x y position
no i'm thinking just the time and the
video that it refers to
just like a video yes right
so it refers to so you can do things
like you can say
uh you know the difference between two
video positions
is a time
i mean or
this may be a bad idea this may be a bad
idea
um
i mean i was thinking it's like geo
position on the earth versus geo
position on the moon which we can do
um
it's a bad idea i think
yeah okay so you're proposing a video
position that simply returns the moment
in the timestamp at which in seconds
presumably at which such and such a
thing happens in a video
yes
okay
but the question is what the thing is
well i think it could be as generic as
when does
steven show up in the video or when does
stevens start to speak in a video
so could could be based on any
any of the audio or video tracks any
custom criteria or something like what
are the positions starting positions of
constant frames
when are the positions of slight change
if you're going through a slideshow
so there could be a list of presets as
well as custom functions we can define
right
well i mean okay this looks like it's
somewhat uncooked at this point
but see scene detection
yeah all of these are uncooked but scene
detection i i think with the method
level that we are looking at now
might be reasonable now i understand
what roger is saying might be more
appealing as far as
goals for splitting the scene i still
think the second argument could remain
to be the number of scenes we think we
would like to split the video to but
maybe that property could be removed for
for the time being well okay what is it
what does it return does it return a
list of timestamps or does it return a
video that's been split
list of timestamps see that second note
t11 t12 and onward it returns a list of
intervals but but you know let me let me
comment on this it's like
uh
graph connected components
or
connected connected graph components
okay
we've got connected components and then
we ended up needing connected graph
components because we wanted to actually
get the pieces of the graph that were
disconnected as opposed to just get the
numbers of which nodes were in each
connected component that is the idea of
the third argument where you can select
what you want your output to be
or what property for each of the
detected scenes you want to
yeah i understand i understand i think
that's a little bit obscure because i
think yes
yes i think the use case here
look i think there are a couple of
obvious use cases one is
this um
essentially position detection
which is not really a scene detect
that's more like video position
and the other is split my video i think
into multiple scenes maybe i'm wrong
about that
but that seems useful
i think if you scroll slightly down
i committed it just before the meeting
so you don't have it but i was thinking
video split could also
video split as well as some other
functions could have
seen aware functionality like like split
based on or
extract frames sample frames based on
scenes or something like that
right i think it's more cooking i don't
think it's worth us going more into this
right now unless you have more input i
mean i think it's obviously a good thing
in general but it obviously needs some
development
okay
um
okay
vote on
our live streams commenting that people
usually use obs virtual cameras as a
webcam source for zoom etc
you can use obs for sure i mean is that
is that how i mean obs is a specific
application isn't it
what is obs
it's a thing that one uses for fancier
uh
streaming stuff
i mean
i've many kind of
things i've done that involve broadcast
media and so on
they you know want me to connect obs i'm
sure i have it on my machine but let me
not start it because it will probably to
produce some horrifying results here
totally confused i would assume that
that would show up in our
possible list of imaging devices
if not that would be an interesting
thing
to potentially add if there is a use
case yeah i mean there is definitely i
mean people ask for this
if you ask
uh
danielle or our video team people you
know that many many different times
i've had to use it for one thing or
another i think there are good chances
that this will all magically work but i
am not sure i am
i'm going to have not died so
okay
all right onward we go here
convert an image of it to graphics and
set options
good
[Music]
i mean so if i take for example
um
a random fishy thing
an image object well there's an image
object
okay and so i now
say um
graphics of that uh somebody by the way
is heavy breathing in there
okay so then then now
whereas that
why is it by the way that the color of
the
border is exactly the same between
graphics and images when we have a
different color
for for example um
graph
it goes back to version seven
that's the same box um all over i i
guess we could change that we should
consider changing it i think i think
it's very useful to see that you've got
an image versus your graphics
okay maybe not change it too much but
change it so that at least if you know
what you're looking for you can see the
difference
okay so what is this graphic is it an
image what is it is it a raster inside
this one is graphics of a raster yes
so it always converts it
and now you can say frame goes to
true
axes axes label whatever in that
graphics call you can add all graphics
options now
i see
that's nice so if i say frame ticks
why didn't that work
i don't know i'll look into that what
coordinate system does it think it has
um zero weight zero height
okay well something's wrong then here
i'll look into that
i mean if we can say
absolute options
okay
okay
okay good
um
all right let me go back to this
image stitch
how are we doing on spherical image
that one we didn't proceed much we
discussed with marcus and jose a couple
of times um but adding the spherical
image as a complete new object is just
was just too big for this release
uh one thing we're adding now an image
stitch and this is another one roger
hasn't seen if you open the page is
projection space being a cylinder or a
plane
what does that mean what is it doing no
normally with image stitch
what what does that mean outdated okay
all right so i don't know what i'm
getting but but um um
explain to me what that roughly means so
so image stitch always returns an image
a rectangular to the image not nothing
beyond that just that we are thinking
we we would like to be able to tell
image stitch whether we should it should
assume the space that was acquired
was
should be seen as a sphere
sorry as a cylinder or as a plane i
think sphere could be another mode we
were thinking with marcus that he marcus
was suggesting maybe not sphere is just
details we had this discussion right
prior to 130 and we thought it was a
good thing it was just not co it was not
ready you know right and and again just
this this release was a little too short
to go into all of that details
okay
but but i mean like a cylindrical thing
when you capture from a camera the
camera is a point capturing device
what does it mean that is capturing the
stuff for a cylinder
or does it go up and down are you
imagining the camera goes up and down
and captures the different heights
right
so at that point i think it's more of a
spherical space that we're looking at
and projecting on a sphere probably
makes a better
the the thing is that we would like to
optimize so that the smallest amount of
skewedness is coming back in into those
images
if the space was cylindrical we project
it on a plane all of the corners are
just going to go off
right
okay let's move on here unless unless
you want to talk more about image stitch
no that's fine there's just placements
what does that mean for one thing yeah
this is motion from one frame to another
uh image displacements is a dense uh
displacement computation image feature
track is a sparse to both of them we are
adding animated image support
and for image displacements we have
defeated in an animated image as an
input yes yes
okay
what's the relationship between video
and animated image
animated image currently is in core all
the time
and it's just displaying as an animated
image smaller
decoration around it it actually looks
very similar to our minimal video
so if i want to do video operations on
an animated image how do i do that
do i say video of animated image and i
go to down with video yes
okay
and does it tell me if i try and apply a
video operation to an animated image
does it just work and do the conversion
automatically or does it complain
i think it complains volumes at the
moment
yep
okay so once it says what to do i think
it's okay
any dimensions yes that makes a lot of
sense
okay text recognized i mean how
i was using text recognized for
something recently and it was
not doing as well as i had hoped it
would
i mean is that in whatever the um
no the it says pending it's the new
update is not and it's still tesseract
that is the engine
and a lot of other commercial software
can do better than tesseract um
at some point we should really look into
these functions and make them better
i mean it was doing surprisingly
decently last i knew about it
is there an issue with quality or speed
or both
quality
that was pretty good this is pretty good
yes
and i was gonna say i recognized and
translated happily some japanese
document earlier this week
that was
that was a good positive surprise
yeah i mean i've seen it
huh wow
now if i do five pixel blurring
wow
let's kill it
and there's gone
okay
i don't consider that a terrible result
i mean
let's just see whether visually we can
see what's going on there or not
that will be really hard i mean i can
read it through this
but i admit that's hard
um
okay let's move on here
create smaller animated gifs
this was a pretty big deal because we
saved some
giant animated gifs in a rough pages
i see
and i mean this is just the the gif
looks the same but it has a smaller
footprint because it's changed its color
map
color map as well as the other note just
below says we are
adding
support for removing redundant frames
okay
good
there is one thing in the front end that
um i need to talk to john about uh our
animations cannot have different frame
durations
it's always the fix fixed frame duration
so if we generate some png for instance
that has removed redundant frames so
each frame now has different durations
uh we we import it as an anime animated
image we don't display them correctly
we compute some average frame rate and
use that throughout that seems wrong
right i'll talk to john to see if there
is any plan for supporting different
frame durations
okay
most of those are consistency updates
raster size versus image size
are some of the are any of these
incompatible changes
no
okay
oh yes actually um
the the color space one is
a small inconsistent backward
incompatible for different
image formats
color space used to return different
results rgb as a string rgb color as a
string rgb color as a symbol
now all of those are becoming consistent
but i made a note of it for backwards
incompatibility change okay wait a
minute what does the color space
function do
color space element of image
image formats
i see
wait a minute so i've got i've got an
image here
and then i say
and then i say here color space is that
right image color space no no images
don't have properties image color space
is an option
option
as as a function sorry
that's not very helpful
what does that mean
carlo i think that's a bug in uh copy
image from videos
this should probably just
create an rgb image
i think it does
okay well let's take a look at the
symmetry is that the is that the
graphics is that
what are you copying is that a graphics
of an image
don't question
the image there yeah
yeah i
i'm not sure
use
use use the image in your blur command
stephen i'll look into this one to see
if
um that's right but this one you
captured from your screen so i expect
this one to be an rgb image
what the heck is that is that the name
of a color space as a string
yes
which is what we need in the color space
functions
in color space elements of yes exactly
of uh image formats all right okay
multi-part images how do you
how how do you export to a multi-part
image i don't think we need to we we
don't yet
and i really think this is such a narrow
use case that i really don't think it's
worth spending more time on this is the
thing where you have where it's
capturing that little live thing and
things like that
no exr is doing what it's doing the
multiple
what does it do sometimes multiple
resolutions sometimes multiple depths
and in order to store those in an open
exr sometimes those are
stored as different uh levels i think
they're called in open xr sometimes
there are multiple parts there are we
haven't yet found any open ex our sample
that has multiple parts as well as
multiple levels in the same file they
are how do we change that
we bring back as a list of images or an
association
associations
okay
okay
anything exciting about our xls updates
no
bug fix says keeping the library up
today
net cdf you import elements like
structure graph okay
ah
okay 160 bio formats bringing in
biosequence generating biosequence
object so what
no this is importing images or image
metadata
formats we did have we had we had
developed bio format link as a packet
and it has been available on our github
for a while now we are registering those
extensions that it can import
in our system and whenever this is a gpl
bioformat is the gpl library so bio
format link is also a gpl packet we have
released on github now if somebody asks
to import a format that we can identify
supported by bio format links we
put up a dialogue installed by bioformat
link and use it to import automatically
so that's the addition that that is
happening now
okay
and we have some of these um
there is a string called video formats
you know this is bio it maybe it should
be called bio image formats or something
but
um well i mean yeah so is there a string
jim saying we don't have all of these
video encoders like you you looked at
those are in principle separate formats
that's a huge list
so we have
a few things are named like mp4
have their separate names otherwise they
are sort of video formats
we have a registered format it's the
event called video formats
i see which is a catch all video formats
now
roger is saying this bio format is a
catch all for bio image formats
i see well we don't want to call it bio
formats that's completely crazy
yeah i i see that i see the source of
confusion bio formats is the name of
that library that we use the paclet is
called bio format links i i think bio
image formats make sense as a register
what are they i mean what kinds of
things are they images that are
microscopes like leica and other ones
other vendors are creating but do they
have img
file extensions
yes if you open the bio formats i have
listed the extensions that we registered
to this bio formats
just open the
yeah
yeah i haven't organized them now not
here
in in the old tab formats
oh gosh i can't land this airplane
two down from your cursor
yeah
i think these should be sorted
alphabetically stephen
yeah i mean this is i think we've got a
plan to change this anyway bio formats
is that right bio
format oh my god
that's the extension list roger was
suggesting we categorize them better it
may be in a table or something
but
i see for videos
we also have a gazillion extensions is
that true yeah yeah open video formats
yeah i believe you
so i mean but our importer
will
automatically know
i i'm very confused here because
the import and export if if you have an
ohm or whatever this is a you know
a dot
you know stp or something
it will know i assume these these things
don't collide
exactly we have picked stp
that it is supposed to use this thing
but what difference does it make that
there is a quotes bio formats
uh import export type other than
documentation
because there is more than exactly as
you guessed there are more extensions
that bioformats can handle but the rest
of them collide with our registered
formats
and so if somebody wants to enforce
bioformats to be used for importing them
then they can use bioformats
oh gosh
okay well how many collisions are there
uh 160 minus the list of extensions i
have there
okay we can get more information on i i
can compute that obviously but
but i mean my question
uh is that what we've done in other
cases i mean is that what we do with
video
with video i believe we didn't have
collision with um
extensions or maybe we had carlo do you
remember
we registered formats
and so forth
don't count them stephen i'm getting the
count
i'm going to count them i'm just going
to say
string count
and then i'm going to count the number
of periods in here
and there are 170. so how many do you
think there should be
well i thought it should be less than
one oh yeah
one minus 10 we're getting now well
against other collisions another
performance
maybe they're
i'm wondering if some of them yeah
different extensions for the same format
might be the
well you know jpeg has a bunch of
yeah
an olm has two dots in them right yeah i
see that
oh it has two dots
yeah that's gonna mess things up here
okay well
my data is off by several ohms
um
okay
anyway i i mean
it is slightly bothersome that
oh gosh
when when one sees a video file like on
the web
one doesn't usually
i mean
i'm confused i mean i don't download
video files very often from the web but
if i did would i see dot
um ffmpeg blah blah blah all the time
no no dc
containers which most popular ones are
mp4
avi not so much okay so these don't have
containers these are just raw
you know an afm is not an atomic force
microscope or maybe it is an atomic
force microscope but it's just some file
correct
yes
so i'm wondering whether we
unfortunately have to make separate
documentation pages for all of these
you had suggested that before as well i
i don't necessarily object to the idea
just that it's tediously a lot of work
well okay fair enough but i mean pct and
picked i believe those are well picked
to certainly an old-fashioned
you know mac bitmap format and things
but i think we can do something that's
intermediary stephen like this could
have
a little bit more informative groupings
like now
unless you really know what this key
means
you're kind of uh you don't really know
anything
yeah but it's not clear you care i mean
my main issue is
if i've got a such and such microscope
in my lab
and
you know there's a certain argument if
it saves a file as a
lut file or something then i just try
importing the file it works an unhappy
person
unless there are all kinds of weird
options you need i i'm just not sure
what what to make of this
i i have in fact documented nifty as one
example dot nii dot img as a nifty file
is something i've attempted to document
just that again i'm i'm a little afraid
it's going to be too much of
documentation work
well i mean for
my goodness somebody
yeah well right yes i understand
well i mean it's it's about as many
formats as we have i mean it's doubling
it's almost doubling
that's cool
i mean if i was kind of
completely worthless i mean
you know if i was convinced this is
going to bring us as many customers as
as the number of formats yes
amira mesh i happen to know what the
mira is
it's uh it's a spinner from conrad zuze
technology in berlin that did
visualization for bio
something rather you're right
well it's not the original khan at zuzer
it's the kanad zusa institute which is
different yes yes yes i mean
who who remembers the original country
except you yeah
yeah right well whoever remembers it's
like all these buildings at universities
that are named after people
right
i don't know about you but you know
whenever i go into these buildings i
always go and look at the the painting
and the plaque and the people who work
in the building look at me doing that
and they're like what the heck
nobody ever does that nobody's you know
people have worked in the building for
you know 30 years and they've never read
the plaque
right
uh
okay so i mean this is perfectly real
format
oh it's part of thumb of fisher okay
yeah
thermofish is sort of a big acquirer
yeah i know i know it's like a
it's like a container like mpeg like mp4
or something no i'm just joking um but
but seriously in
look if these are real formats i just
think we should have a stylized way of
making pages for them and make a bunch
of pages
i don't disagree i think if if he can
pick a handful of those that that are
worth
um splitting off i'm happy to do that
well fine and then we can we can
basically
investigate the others and see whether i
mean i don't know i we have to check for
these name collisions things like that
um
okay i don't think we have a good way of
handling that in the documentation
um
you know
names of pages and things
okay but any case
this
you know bio image formats
or bio image format or something
i don't know video format we actually
call it video format singular so maybe
this one as well bio image format that's
what it should be each one is a format
yes
positioned text
i want back to graphics improvements
okay
set format properties
those actually are not gonna make it
yeah it's just gonna ask you yeah it was
a little bit dicey last time so
well but this is what this is the
register importers and exporters and
things yeah so you too can add a nerd
yes importer
yes um
okay summary element for all formats
what is that that is not making it
either but the idea is that uh some
formats have the summary element and
it's really useful at the framework
level we're gonna add a summary element
so that if the specific converter like
for wave files don't have the summary
element implemented the framework is
going to return some minimal useful
information
about the file
but the summary
is about a file or it's a general
sort of thing about that format it's
about the file
yeah
this file
this big this resolution
this space it's a text string about the
file
yes no it's
it's a data set
oh
so i mean for example if i were to
not that i have if i were to take um
uh where is my
fish example fish
um
if i would take that
yeah
export that
yeah just that just that yes
import of that comma summary
that's nice
i didn't know we had these
yeah
they're not all everywhere but they're
in many many places by now
it's really useful that is useful it
should be better documented
i mean it is i think in most
formats it's the second example yeah on
their basic example i'm just not seeing
it
okay
and then the last item their options
element has been a very confused and
confusing
element for all formats sometimes it
returned
settings default settings for options
available to import sometimes it was
returning options that would show up in
the returned object
and i don't know what was the purpose of
that anyways we discussed it we thought
it would be harmless to at least
undocument those we are going to keep
them for backwards compatibility but
there is probably very little use or
usefulness to those
fine
okay
uh purkinje on our live stream is
commenting that it's got exr is useful
for light field cameras
um
okay well i think we made it through the
through the whole list
perfect time
um
uh yeah you know
there's lots more to do
yeah and it's a lot longer than that so
this is not even yeah right okay
um okay great well very nice um what's
our next design review
i think we have one
tomorrow which one was tomorrow
it was
uh visualization we've got a
visualization on tomorrow
okay
well good stuff all right thanks very
much and thanks to folks on the live
stream and um